Film Courage: [Reading comment] “Sorry
guys this entire theory doesn't hold water
at all. The massive breakthrough success of
the MCU [The Marvel Cinematic Universe] has
done almost NOTHING (in all caps) to increase
the sales of Marble comics. As a matter of fact
the books are struggling big time (look it up).
Conversely, Iron Man was a lesser-known Marvel
hero when his movie dropped, and the Guardians
of the Galaxy were mostly obscure comic book
d-listers, both suggesting that it wasn't comic
readers that made the movies succeed it was also
the QUALITY of the Marvel movies, AS MOVIES,
that made people care. So yeah, go ahead and
try to launch a comic and/or novel and/or video
game while you simultaneously meet the herculean
task of shooting and promoting an indie
movie. Good luck there, you will need it.”
Houston Howard, Transmedia Author/Speaker: Sure,
yeah, absolutely. I think if you pull that apart
a little bit there's a couple interesting
things that I would respond to because I
want to have empathy for that comment and the
comments…interesting and I'll take the middle
comment there first about the herculean task
of trying to do it simultaneous of a movie.
That's crazy. You should never try to be doing it
simultaneous to the film. I would never advocate
you trying to create a comic book while you're
trying to make a movie. That's crazy. You should
never do that. You should be creating the comic
book well before you ever make the movie for sure.
Anybody that's ever made a movie knows how
all-encompassing it is to make a movie. You
can't do anything. You can barely feed yourself
and pay your bills and take your dogs on the walk
while you're trying to at the same time of making
a movie. Your whole life stops just so you can do
it there's no way you're going to be able to be
managing the production of a mobile game and the
production of an album and the and the production
of a comic book while you're making a movie so
so I would 100 agree with the comment about that
don't do it let's just avoid that altogether now
that doesn't mean you shouldn't make a comic book
and a movie let's just make him at different times
right so now before you ever make the movie let's
make the comic book to then grow the audience in
a way that that establishes pre-awareness in the
market I mean think about this think about think
about you when you make a movie that's not based
on let's just say you find the financing let's
just say hypothetically you find magical financing
your grandma leaves you a hundred thousand dollars
in her will so that you can make your your
movie so you make a hundred thousand dollar
feature film which is awesome right you have
the financing to do it if it's unbranded content
when you release the movie you're releasing it
to to no fans by definition there aren't any
fans because this has never been released in the
market before it's unbranded content you haven't
you haven't pushed it out at all so there isn't
anyone who loves it yet and it could be great I'm
not saying it's not great no one knows about
it yet because the movie's not out yet right
so you're releasing it into the market with no
fans just hoping and praying that everybody shows
up on opening weekend so we can consider this a
success right so now look at look at the other the
the other path is we know that that it's it's that
any movie one when you start production it's gonna
be two years before that movie ever sees a lot
of day but even even if you go through the the
normal pre-production principle photography
post-production distribution process but let's
say even before you get to that to to to the
production standpoint leading up to it right
you go ahead and establish the market say with a
comic book or podcast let's just say podcast right
so you say you launch the podcast ideally
maybe podcast and comic book right but let's
just stick with one let's say let's say podcast
if you have 10 000 people who love your podcast
that is connected narratively to the movie that
you will you will be releasing in the future
right so you you you open the
brand up to 10 000 people who love
the narrative universe the story the characters
the concept like they're in it right and then
and now they're your fans they're in your brand
they're supportive because we love this podcast
it's awesome we're fans of this whole thing when
you make your movie and release your movie guess
what you're doing you're going to release the
movie and there's 10 000 fans that already love it
they already love it they may not love the
movie yet but they love the brand and releasing
a movie to 10 000 fans who already love it
is better than releasing a movie to no fans
that to no fans right like that like that
that's the punch line is it's of course like
think about this if if I if I if I release if I
release a podcast and I and I create 10 000 fans
and then I release a novel I release that novel
into a market that's warm it's a warm market not a
cold market now i've warmed the market with 10 000
fans now there's 10 000 fans that can buy my book
and then let's say I get 20 bucks per book do the
math 10 000 times 20. that equals out to a profit
potential as opposed to not doing anything first
and then just releasing my novel into the market
to zero fans does that does that mean that
there's no way for me to make money of course
not the people that do that make money in
books all the time but it's a harder road
to release to no fans than it is to release to
10 000 fans it's reductive thinking you almost
have to make yourself a little bit dumber
to use common sense for that to make sense I
feel like we're overthinking it like of course
it's better to have ten thousand fans already
loving your stuff when you release your movie
of course of course right I mean it just it
just it just makes sense it and so so whatever
way you can establish the community of fans
any community of fans that love your brand and
love your ip ahead of the release of the movie
then when you release that movie you're
gonna increase your chances for success
does it guarantee success of course not but
you have a higher chance of success than if you
release that same movie into a cold market that's
the punchline now then if you add in the fact that
there's probably not you're you've minimized your
chance of gaining investment from a private equity
investor or studio because it's unbranded content
right like that that's a whole other conversation
that that just to get the financing you need to
have that market presence by and large that comes
by way of attachment or by by brand awareness of
the ip right but but so so there's lots of reasons
you need to do this but I completely agree you
shouldn't do at the same time it'll make you go
crazy right that's that it'll make your marriage
fall apart and make you grow a crazy beard and
make you stressed out like it's just it's bad
news like you shouldn't you should not try to
juggle all the like the filmmaking is so crazy and
difficult we all know being on set it's just too
difficult to do all those things at the same time
right spread them out warm the market then release
the movie so that's the middle comment the second
thing I'll address about the comment really is the
first part of the comment where the the commenter
said that the the MCU didn't boost sales of Marvel
comics and and and I would agree with that as well
I would I would absolutely I'm agreeing with the
commenter more than I'm disagreeing with commenter
the commenter because there's a narrative reason
for that is is when they when Kevin Feige launched
the MCU it was a different canon than the comics
and so canon is sort of the official narrative
that goes along with a franchise or an ip
and so what is the official story and there were
I mean there was what 70 years or of Marvel comic
narrative that had been going on forever and
and when they started the MCU they wanted to
start a new canon because that was way too much
complexity way too much baggage way too much
story to deal with adequately it just confines the
filmmakers too much right because because there's
the only way you can make this movie
is you if you go read 3 000 comic books
that doesn't become an attractive entry
point for filmmaker to want to do right so
so it's just too much baggage and so they they
they said the MCU will be a special cannon it's
going to be a new canon that the comic books will
still be the thing will be a thing and they'll
still have their own canon they'll have their own
stories that will continue but we're going to set
up a new completely fresh consistent canon that
starts with the MCU that won't just be the movies
they actually have a line of comic books that
that is a special MCU line of comic books that's
tied in with the MCU that goes along with the
MCU but those comic books aren't part of the
the legacy Marvel comic books that that that that
are out there and so yeah of course when when when
when the iron man movies and the avengers movies
and all these movies came out they didn't boost
sales of the comic books because the comic books
didn't extend the story of the movies and so
from a transmedia perspective the incentive for
the audience to migrate to a different platform
is that the the story in the different platform is
going to give them more insight and more narrative
and more payoff of this the thing that they love
and so if they were to learn more about this these
movies and the tv shows and things like that by
going to the comic books maybe they would have
but because all Marvel fans knew that with new
Marvel fans or even legacy fans that there was
a disconnected canon there was no incentive
for them to go check out the check out the
comic books and and and I don't think kevin feige
at Marvel necessarily intended for these things
to to for the the comic book sales to spike
so that's why they didn't spike they broke the
canon and there was never a business objective
or a creative objective of Kevin Feige who's
over the puppet master of the MCU and so so so
so of course of course those didn't spike now
does that mean see this is we don't want to
we don't want to conflate that to say well
that means comic books connected with with with
movies don't work and there's no reason because
they no it they can make it work like if the
canon would be consistent with with the the film
and television and and they work together now all
then all of a sudden they begin to feed each other
you look at the the difference in how Marvel
treated the legacy the the legacy comics
with Marvel and and compare that to how Lucasfilm
deals with the comic books in star wars it's very
different and so all of a sudden you watch the
sequel trilogy and you have Kylo Ren who is who is
the head of the Knights of Ren and and in
the movies the knights of ren aren't really
explained like who they are and how how he got
roped in with those with that crew seemed just
like it's a kid that kind of got involved with
some bad friends that took him in a bad direction
they sort of allude to it so you can still enjoy
the movie without all that backstory knowledge
right but they revealed who the Knights of Ren
are what happened to to ben solo after he left
Luke Skywalker's Jedi academy and kind of went off
on his own and and they tell that complete story
in comic books and so now the comic books is
is now extending the film franchise the trilogy
and now there's synergy between the two
things and so now obviously we have film
fans who are migrating over to the comic book does
everybody migrate of course not everybody migrates
right but you get your the the comic books
do absolutely benefit from the migration
of a certain percentage of the film fans
that want to dig deeper and know more
or there are some people that haven't seen the
movies that are into the comic books then find
the entry point in the comic books and then find
their way over to the movies because they are now
interested in the Knights of Ren and that's part
of the movies and so it can flow both ways right
so so you absolutely see spikes in sales when
there's intentional narrative synergy what I call
additive comprehension between the works right but
that's an intention that needs to be made from a
business perspective a business model perspective
and also a narrative intention that goes along
with that you've got to tie these stories together
in a very intentional way to have that happen if
you don't intend it from a business perspective
and you don't intentionally tie these stories
together narratively of course you'll never see
a spike but that doesn't that doesn't lead you
to a conclusion of you should never have a comic
book right like like that that's it's a complete
like it depends on how you execute the comic book
and how you and how you execute it in the context
where it goes along with the film it's the
contextual information that you kind of need to be
able to make that work right so so so absolutely
uh the the the commenter is right in the analysis
but I think the conclusion that's inferred from
that analysis is is incorrect you just don't
want to conflate it and apply it to oh you never
need to do a comic book comic books are dumb like
you don't need to get to that conclusion let's
just do it in the right way if you intend it if
you intend to spike that means you have to do it
the right way that's all that means they didn't
star wars actually did this with with what they
called the extended universe which they when when
Lucasfilm or when Lucasfilm was sold to Disney
they had been writing novels and comic books and
and especially novels for 20 years and there were
hundreds of novels and video games and comic books
all the stuff that Disney inherited by way of the
purchase not just the original film trilogy of the
prequel trilogy there were there were hundreds and
hundreds of of of licensed works that were created
and it was too much for Lucas or for Disney to
figure out so they de-canonized all that stuff
and said this isn't an official story anymore from
from at this point on we're creating new canon
we're disconnecting from this other stuff right so
so so in the same way the new stuff that they've
released doesn't spike the sales of all that
extended universe stuff that that that's older
because there's a narrative disconnect right and
it's not their business intention so of course
whenever you have that disconnect it's not gonna
it's not gonna achieve that result and I don't
think they're disappointed in it because they
never intended to do that in the first place and
the last part of the comment is like talked about
luck with any luck this would have of course you
listen nothing's ever guaranteed everything
like whether it's luck or kismet or or
fate or destiny whatever it is like of course
there's always going to be an element of of
right place right time uh what do you call
it luck we call it just whatever you call it
karma I don't know there's there's something that
that this x factor that has to happen for things
to be to pop off to be successful know if anybody
ever tells you that there's a guaranteed way or a
guaranteed model of success in the film industry
or the creative industry or creative content
production that there's a guaranteed methodology
of like the silver bullet do this every time and
it's gonna pop and and be amazing and be huge if
anybody ever says that you need to you need to run
the opposite direction because it's not true it it
all you can have the best laid plans you can have
the best stories the best ideas the best business
model and and sometimes it just doesn't work for
a thousand different reasons and it's not because
your business model is bad and it's not because
your idea was bad or you're like just sometimes it
doesn't work and it's weird and and it's just like
and or sometimes culturally something it happens
in it and something pops off in a just right place
right time the right idea and who knew that Baby
Yoda would blow up the way Baby Yoda did like
like it was that luck was that right place
right time what like what was it I don't know
and so so yeah like this anything that I say is
is not silver bullet I think anybody that writes
a screenwriting book of like this is the way to
structure a screenplay that's not a guarantee
if you use the structures to guarantee that
your screenplay is going to sell or be good
of course not of course you need some
element of quote unquote luck in addition
to best laid plans and and and and and approaches
that increase your chances right that's all I’m
saying is if you if you use a multi-platform
approach to attack the market in as many ways
possible to use all the tools and toolbox generate
audience have a market presence for your ip
be able to to to create an ecosystem that feeds
itself in a commoditized market before you get to
the big st the big film and television investment
heavy things that are so risky for people and
they don't want to lose their jobs because they
don't want to take the risk if you just do that
stuff it doesn't guarantee you selling anything
it doesn't guarantee you succeeding in anything
it increases your chances from a sports analogy
if you just take an unbranded piece of content
and and you just release it into the market
and you try to sell the script you try to
you just you just you just put it out there right
it's like it's like with the football analogy it's
like being back on your own one yard line throwing
a hail Mary all the way down the field right
that's hard like it's rare that that works it's
very difficult right and and does does every now
and then does does it work for somebody of course
and that's the trap you see somebody on the other
a few feet down from you say oh they completed
their pass that means I can complete my pass which
is true technically it's true but you may spend
20 years trying to throw that same hail Mary down
the field and never and it just doesn't work and
that's not your fault and it's just not doesn't
mean you're a bad person or a bad creative it just
didn't work so what I say is let's run a few plays
to move down the field a little bit let's do the
five yard podcast let's do the 15 yard comic book
let's do the seven yard board game right and let's
get to the point to where we're at the 50-yard
line and throw the hail Mary because everything
in the film industry is going to be a hail Mary
everything even the studios with the stuff
that they do is going to be hail Mary's
nothing's guaranteed right but every especially
for independent filmmakers everything that
we make is going to be hail Mary so but I
would rather throw the hell Mary from the 50
than my own one that's all I'm saying it increases
your odds increases your chances but you do have
that have to have that little piece of magic you
have to have that little piece of magic or luck
or whatever you call it in order for these things
to work and that's that's the cool thing about the
industry right you just there's it's not ones and
zeros like the matrix there's there's something
else that that that comes in to all the stuff that
you make and and and it makes something come alive
and that's cool and then that's interesting
and that makes what makes it exciting so
so I agree with almost every single thing in
that comment which is which is but maybe I have
a different perspective or a different angle in it
and sorry for those of us who don't know football
what is the definition of that type of past oh
okay yeah sorry I forget no that's okay yeah so
so hail Mary is is uh just it's usually your last
resort you're way far back on the other end of the
field and and you just like throw it way up in the
air and just hope that somebody catches it right
it's not really a a well-designed tactical play
it's the hail Mary let's just hope and pray that
something happens and it works right like that's
that's that's the hail Mary and it usually only
happens when teams are getting ready to lose and
they're running out of time and there's nothing
else to do except throw really far down the field
really high in the air and just see what happens.